if you're watching this game kicks your
ass that's how I saw it playing out
[Music]
[Music]
separate wanna review can you lead off
the words that were passed laughing here
there now in effect the next one is
quite part of the biggest one which is
the homegrown player right so if want to
make sure everybody understands it
because it starts with next year's minor
league draft well but it impacts like
your first-round pick for next year that
everybody gets right after we finish the
auction you're 2019 first-round pick is
implicated in this so any guy that you
originally select as a minor leaguer and
you don't waive him you don't treat him
he never leaves your roster now follows
a different salary trajectory so after
his qualifying season that we now call
s2 he goes to h6 and you then have the
ability to keep that guy for up to six
years you would start off $5.00 s2 then
he would go h6 $5 h5 seven dollars each
for $9 h3 $18 each to $20 each one
[Music]
think more than any other season that we
we've had previously this group has been
super quick to act on the big names 17
1921 for me 21 21 20 25 27 plus 1 is 8
28
so and fantasy baseball there's like a
strategy that a lot of people seem to be
laughing that's that stars and scrub
strategy you either go for the big easy
to predict reliable players and spend
over spend essentially on them and then
hopefully with kind of like their
leftover dollars you're able to find a
couple times it's rough it's a lot of a
lot of times it's a crapshoot
anyway so with a 20 team League there's
a lot less depth so you wanna if you
want to overpay for the cream of the
crop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Gordon Sophie Gordon one for $60
whereas I paid 35 for Billy Hamilton but
Hamilton gets more steals and that's why
do you earn micro so much so who do you
think's done the best today honestly I'm
not I'm not really sure
I think thing this year everyone is
doing pretty terribly and a lot of
people feel that way pretty much
planning to pun to next year I'm feeling
bad that in a bad job I'm happy to spend
times with friends not happy with my
baseball team's future came into the
year ready to pack it in feel as if I
did some good things but overall about
that go ahead
to actually see he's not a good power on
your bar graph you want to be in twice
[Music]
I'm super tired because I had my draft
yesterday that's how we prepped
throughout prep my draft happy where we
are they were happy yeah right those
dollars left
yeah dollars left and I like for my team
is so I think we're good
none that front so we're about there now
of course the end game killing maker
killer I've kinda said on my roster so
that next hour and a half I have two
guys I really want I'll see if I can get
there you know standouts at all I think
I've done both some of the least
terrible miss so far so I'm happy about
that
I think what Best Picture still a con
which is kind of weird with like 30
minutes left in the auction but I really
like my delino deshields pick like 24
too harsh definitely think he's like
he's gonna have a big season a lot of
steals and Wendy going for 60 I feel
good about
and I've been on the Dan Vogel Bach
train for a couple years now and I think
this might be the year so he's a big
target of mine I think I'm a good shot
at him
I think Zhang is that a solid job I
think a lot of the contenders kind of
like last year haven't put themself over
the top with the great draft I think a
lot of people who to know they're not
gonna win this year I've done a good job
getting like cheap high upside guys like
stats and AJ and I think I find myself
in between going for and taking again
you guys out of everyone have also
consumed the most alcohol how do you
think that's affecting you should I
think well that's not true because yup
ken is outpacing us you put us together
you think your kids having tomato juice
and you're grossly mistaken young good
focus is gonna be on a it's gonna be on
pitching you're out focus should be on
2019 first time gonna be able to compete
you think so yeah I think well I've been
worried year ahead of that I think 2018
will be there
frankly hoping to trade with Gary he
looks like a front-runner potentially
just told me he's going for it so I
might be trying to make some moves there
there's a couple other guys so my goal
now is to sell my entire team in about
an hour and in exactly one year from now
be talking to you about how I'm going to
win this whole thing
[Music]